[Musique]
marguerite duras scénariste hiroshima
mon amour et réalisatrice de dix longs
métrages dont le film india s'en va
sortir bientôt
et tous ceux qui l'ont vu on dit que
quelque chose a changé dans le cinéma
depuis india sans chantal akerman qui à
24 ans a réalisé deux longs métrages
dont le dernier dont j'oublie toujours
le titre parce qu'il est assez lent
voulez-vous lui rappelé l'édile man 23
quai du commerce 1080 bruxelles va
sortir à la rentrée en septembre et
liliane de kermadec dont le film aloyse
remporte un succès son plan de la
critique actuellement à paris et elles
ont un point en commun toutes ces trois
rédactrices et qu'elles ont fait tourner
et delphine seyrig et je voudrais
demander d'abord à delphine seyrig elle
a tourné avec dix sept réalisateurs en
ont pour la seconde année et tout d'un
coup en une année elle a tourné avec ces
trois femmes et est ce qu'elle peut nous
dire est ce que pourrai me dire delphine
s'il ya une spécificité des femmes
réalisatrices par rapport aux autres il
est temps je crois pas que sais je sais
même pas très bien ce que veut dire
spécificité c'est à dire que oui
effectivement j'ai tourné presque tous
les films que j'ai faits avec des
réalisateurs et non seulement exécuté
réalisateur mais enfin disons
principalement avec des hommes est en
général peu de femmes dans les films et
et les équipes sont masculines et là
effectivement canton je crois que la
question est pas si on veut de chercher
les points communs parce qu'il ya des
différences aussi grande contre des
rennais entre différents réalisateurs
je veux dire les les trois films le film
de liliane le film de chantal une
marguerite sont complètement
complètement différents les uns des
autres mais disons que d'abord il ya une
sauce tout à fait simple et que
n'importe qui peut comprendre c'est que
moi qui suis actrice quand je parle d'un
personnage je parle de mon personnage
c'est forcément un personnage de femme
et quand je parle d'un personnage de
femme avec un réalisateur homme ou avec
une réalisatrice c'est forcément très
différent parce que quand je parle avec
une sam
on parle d'une pas d'une même personne
mais d'une personne du même sexe
de même que j'imagine que pour les
acteurs ça doit être ils sont toujours
avec des réalisateurs sommes donc quand
ils parlent de leur personnage avec un
autre homme
ils doivent savoir ce que c'est je peux
dire c est pour les femmes sont très
rares pour les actrices est très rare de
parler avec une autre faille vous dire
que l'équipe de chantal akerman est une
équipe presque exclusivement féminine
vous l'avez voulu comme c'est un
chantage alors racontez nous cette
équipe est composée de deux qui il ya
une caméra ou manili à une directrice
one à une ingénieuse du songe sais pas
comment on dit oui à une directrice de
la photo il ya une fille qui s'occupait
des cas une autre fille de philippe être
du sou et presque toute l'équipe était
il y avait il y avait un ou deux garçons
mais la plupart étaient des filles et
pourquoi voulez vous ça chante après 12
au pour plusieurs raisons
la première c'est que bon les filles ne
trouvent pas de travail
enfin c'est pas la première et puis ne
trouvent pas de travail dans cet ordre
là il n'y a personne qui va engager une
fille qui fait la caméra il ya personne
qui s'engage et une fille comme
directrice de photos etc
ensuite j'ai déjà travaillé avec des
hommes comme avant et par exemple quand
avec française avec une est clair par
exemple quand je demandais un plan large
je me retrouvais avec un zoom avant sur
le visage ou les mains du la comédienne
qui bougeait à ce moment là et le
preneur de son en quelque sorte oui
parce qu'il n'avait pas le respect parce
que il trouvait par exemple un plan
large comme un film tout en plan large
ça va pas du tout et comme bons
il disait on va lui arranger ça voudrait
voir un extrait de chantal akerman
jeanne dielman 23 quai du commerce 81
bruxelles j'aime pas dit que vous leur
donnerez pas alors ça commence par le
soir elle va préparer le repas pour son
fiscale a tant à l'oral mais les ailes
mais les pommes de terre accueilli au
bout d'un moment sony un homme qui vient
elle rend dans une chambre avec lui il
ressort la chambre avec lui lui donne de
l'argent elle le met dans une soupière
les temps les pommes de terre elle met
la table son fils arrive de l'âge avec
lui il fait réciter sa leçon
elle sort faire un tour avec lui ils se
couchent lendemain matin se lève et lui
prépare le petit déjeuner elle va le
réveiller
elle lui donne l'argent pour partir à
l'école elle fait le vit il fait le
ménage doit faire les courses
elle revient elle mange elle s'en va
l'après-midi acheter des choses qui lui
manque qui lui manquent prend le café
elle revient l'homme arrive et c'est
alors elle fait des choses toujours dans
le même ordre sans jamais se tromper
il n'y a pas de trou dans sa vie c'est à
dire qu a pas d'angoissé pas de moments
creux tout est très très très bien
remplie elle sait exactement par exemple
je pars le matin quand elle met son
peignoir elle sait exactement quel va
commencer par boutonnet le bouton du
haut est terminée par le bouton du bas
ce qui fait que l a pas d'inquiétude et
savvis pascal moment sans problème
vous aussi dire qu'il n'a plus des
inquiétudes et la routine c'est une
lutte contre l' inquiétude
je pense qu'elle se pose pas du tout les
choses comme ça et ne sais pas elle
s'est pas dit je vais avoir une vie très
organisé comme ça je n'aurais pas parce
que malgré ce n'est pas d'hier elle
n'est pas du tout angoissé simplement
disons que elle elle vit sa vie comme ça
jusqu'au jour où est ce que je risque de
faire quelque chose qui se passe est bon
moi j'ai mon interprétation là dessus et
delphi on a une autre de ces deux
explications au bout je crois que ça y
est je crois que chacun pensera ce tu
voudras en voyant le film disons que ça
se déglingue ça se déglingue cdh après
une visite d'un client et c'est à dire
que c'est à partir de ce quotidien si
bien organisée mais les toutes petites
choses et l'oubli d'éteindre la lumière
donc elle de revenir sur ses pas elle
doit refaire le chemin qu'elle a fait
elle s'est réveillée trop tôt le matin à
une heure creuse devant elle et je crois
que c'est tout ce que je veux redire
moi j'ai une autre vision du son à
faciliter toujours la pression du monde
extérieur qui est plus forte je crois
sur les femmes que sur les hommes c'est
c'est mon point de vue je pense que
d'une certaine façon c'est celui chantal
aussi et cette pression du monde
extérieur qu'ils rencontrent
l'angoissent intérieur cette rencontre
qui amendait fait une explosion ce que
tu appelles s'est déglingué
alors il ya d être dans dix ans le
terrain intérieur est plus fragile il
peut recevoir moins de pression que
d'autres elle c'est ça alors il ya
toutes les solutions il ya la force de
la pression extérieure sur un individu
qui n'est pas organisé pour y résister
beaucoup il ya une pression moins forte
sur un individu mieux organisés par oui
et puis c'est passé tout se croit que
même de la chaudière à vapeur
oui et je crois que si on accepte la vie
de ta dire que jeanne dielman au fond a
vécu une vie qu'elle peut-être qu'elle
pensait petite fille que d'avoir un
enfant d'être d'être mari et ça c'est le
wales avait accepté de demain voilà
ravis comme jeanne dielman elle n'aurait
pas explosé de sa centrale de la place
hentgès le principe est le même
aloyse pour moi c'est quelqu'un qui a
refusé tout de suite le mariage les
choses quotidiennes de la vie d'une
femme et qui voulait transcender sa part
le champ d'abord et puis ensuite la
vision de l'empereur ou de ceux chaplin
shekel est évidemment enfin où il y
avait un désir de transcendance cabine
torche aussi une force qui l'empêché
d'accepter justement ce quotidien cette
bottine qui étaient ceux qui étaient
préparés pour elle par son milieu par
son environnement et je crois qu'il faut
beaucoup de force pour accepter aussi la
vie quotidienne baril c'est peut-être
aussi tu vois ce que je veux moi je ne
sens pas en terme de force
je ne ressens jamais l'acceptation en
terme de force
est ce que à lolita quand même pas été
obligé de se réveiller elle aussi dans à
l'intérieur de la ville l'a nommé non
elle s'est jamais résigné mais elle a
elle a accepté disons de vivre dans cet
asile au fond très comme les autres
femmes aussi dans la mesure où elle
s'est mise à repasser
elle a fait accepter ça elle était en
prison elle a décidé que c'était un
couvent donc elle avait décidé que
c'était son libre arbitre c'est comme ça
que son essence
oui c'est ça c'est très différent disons
que sa vie au lieu de faire soit de la
peinture soit d'être cantatrice soit
d'être écrivain ou poètes elle a quand
même passé sa vie à repasser en écrivant
dans les coins et des choses superbes et
en peignant mais il a vécu sa vie c'est
pour ça que l'hétéro hic
moi oui mais enfin il ya quand même une
part de pas de résignation justement un
tué en prison et tu dis non je ne suis
pas en prison et je vis et je sais ce
que je veux ouais une certaine façon et
de marie secrétaires l'héroïne votre
film est en prison aussi
je ne sais pas qui est un monstre et je
ne sais pas qui vous êtes
moi non plus d'ailleurs c'est un
personnage que subit exercé une
fascination depuis des années je pense
que j'ai fait le film pour en savoir
davantage
je ne connais pas d'ailleurs le film se
passe entièrement en s'est entièrement
des choses des éléments de deux voix qui
racontent ce que peut-être ce concert
éléments ont fait d'elle et des autres
personnages d'ailleurs parce qu'il ya
pas qu elles ont construit il ya la
mendiante il ya dont on ne sait rien non
plus simplement qu'elles sont parallèles
en ont cédé pendant la même année
la mendiante et anne-marie serait-elle
oui il ya un périple qui valent environ
fait les capitales de l'asie tandis
commission différents mails unis est une
sorte d'état limites de l'humain ne pas
d'autres définitions que de la mendicité
de la folie et l'autre très bien
c'est officiellement c'est une
ambassadrice et la base alice france
l'ambassadrice de france en inde mais
vous dire qui est laid je crois que ça
ne m'intéresse pas c'est vraiment hors
de la psychologie elle va vers la mort
et tous les manèges au tournoi interne
quelques heures de sa vie le percer les
personnages autour d'elle la regarde le
jeune vitae et le jeune attaché la
regarde
il la découvre comme le spectateur sont
des regards sur un an ils ne connaissent
pas il a qu'un qui la connaît c'est le
vice consul de france à l'art
mais n'en dit rien ouais j'ai
complètement secret je ne sais pas qui
vous êtes
ces films ont été faits quand même avant
là rien à voir avec les résultats de
lassitude veut ou moi je ressens les
choses en terme de langage si tu veux
bon j'ai le sentiment que les femmes
cherchent leur langage
en tant que femme je cherche mon
identité en tant que cinéaste je cherche
mon langage en tant que femme cinéaste
j'ai cherché mon discours
bon je trouves tu peux remplacer cherche
par tran si tu veux alors tu vois c'est
très simple mais les problèmes d'argent
ils sont très graves
ils ne sont pas particulier aux femmes
il s'en écoule dans le cinéma juin dans
la maison qu'il vient de dire tout tels
que tu ne suis pas les films que tu
feras mais tu sais ce que tu ne feras
pas naturellement je connais aussi des
hommes qui sont comme ça et on est là
ici pour parler d'eux non non non bien
sûr
non mais je veux dire que dans ce que tu
ne feras pas - je j'exagère peut-être
mais je sens que ya des choses qui ne
sont pas celles que les âmes refuse
qu'ils sont autre chose que toi tu
refuses parce que tu n'as absolument
ab-so-lu-ment donc un problème d'argent
tant que ça pourquoi moi je gagne ma vie
il se trouve que moi deux ou trois je
suis la seule à vraiment gagner ma vie
dans le sida pas avec nous demeure pas
avec mon ami particulièrement mais
pourquoi c'est parce que je suis une
actrice est qu en tant qu'actrice j'ai
fait ce qu'il était convenu de faire
pour une actrice c'est à dire que j'ai
suivi le modèle qu'il fallait suivre
pour plaire aux hommes disons dans la
mesure qui m'a permis de gagner ma vie
pas au delà
mais on a un mesures qui me permet de
gagner ma vie et c'est ça que je sens
moins qui change avec les personnages
qu'on va voir dans les films des femmes
c'est que à ce moment là ce en tout cas
du point de vue de l'actrice ça va être
complètement différent
on va représenter nous les femmes une
autre image qui sera beaucoup moins
payante puisque l'industrie du cinéma
est entre les mains de des hommes et
d'un certain
de certains critères je pense que le
cinéma des femmes fait partie du cinéma
différent
le cinéma différent est par définition
un cinéma politique il n'ya aucune
comparaison entre un film sur les barres
monsieur vernel est un film tourné par
les jeunes de guerre moderne de nos
moyens financiers ou humaines de moyens
joue les moyens financiers à partir du
chiffre de l'argent dont on dispose et
film est un peu un film politique
le film les filles j'ai jamais été payé
sur le danger j'aime jamais même pas eu
le salaire d'un second assistant du
temps ces politiques sont donc ces
personnels et finalement non récit de
manu gérant les chinois de femmes et
ainsi les maires donc solide qu'on le
veuille ou non c'est un cinéma différent
moi ce que je me demande c'est si
justement ce qui va pas un peut être tu
dis que tu ferais un film certes où là
aussi politique
mais je me demande si la question n'est
pas l'argent voilà la question est ce
qu'on va donner aux réalisatrices femme
de l'argent pour tourner des choses qui
n'auront ni pistolet ni bagnols ni
fesses de femmes peut-être ajouté rita
qu'on leur a pas envie nous demander à
quelqu'un qui a dit très gentil qui
apparaît très gentiment de mon fils mais
qui a dit que c'était pas un ouvrage de
dames
alors je ne sens pas une dame mais je
pense que dans mon ouvrage de femmes et
je pense qu'un jeu il y aura des
ouvrages de femmes qui seront pas
seulement des films et des villes
je demande de cette idée que un ouvrage
de femmes c'est quelque chose de
restrictif
oui mon ouvrage pourquoi ou achètent un
bon mot mais comme tu vas y on ne fait
pas les films qu'on fera mais on sait
les films qu'on ne fera pas aussi bien
des ouvrages de femmes et c'est pas du
tricot non on oublié c'est eric un
ouvrage de femmes seydoux tricot est
d'ores et déjà le schéma différent
[Musique]